sensation encore veuve du défilé
officiel tout à l'heure à moscou la
présence de raïssa gorbatchev très star
avec safed accalmie aujourd'hui au
collège de creil où le travail a repris
à peu près normalement sauf pour les
trois élèves aux foulards consigné en
bibliothèque
les enseignants ont reçu quelques
encouragements syndicaux mais la plupart
des parents en ont assez chantal
kimmerlin patrick raisner la fuite
une sortie désormais ordinaire au
collège gabriel avait samira leïla et
fatima fuit les caméras
c'est le ras-le-bol général les parents
se font de plus en plus rare à la sortie
des classes
hésitant à braver l'agitation commune et
à vivre sous la pression constante des
médias on n'a pas à même nous on n'est
pas tranquille
c'est arrivé parce que nos enfants
soient effectives on demande à ce que
les journalistes reste un petit peu les
enfants bon bah je sais que c'est votre
travail de venir cueillir l'information
des zombies maintenant mon bol on trouve
nous que c'est un peu trop et c'est
regrettable parce que pour trois jeunes
filles qui sont voilées parce qu'elle
alla scala et est de 866 salaires qui
qui est compromise au même moment sur
unis c'est le principal du collège les
enseignants et les deux secrétaires
généraux de la fédération de l'éducation
nationale et du syndicat des
instituteurs une rencontre d'une heure
et demie qui a permis aux enseignants et
aux représentants des syndicats de
confirmer leur position commune
les enseignants sont absolument
déterminés à faire prévaloir les
intérêts de la collectivité sur la
volonté de quelques-uns et nous les
avons encouragés notamment en indiquant
que dans deux jours le slip et j'essaie
prendrait une consigne nationale pour
appeler à continuer à dialoguer partout
où il ya nécessité et en cas où le
dialogue se heurte à un mur
d'intransigeance à faire appliquer les
textes qui interdisent le projet du qui
sont donc ils refusent les enfants il ne
refuse pas les enfants les enfants
refusent les lois de l'école laïque
il est clair que les syndicats
d'enseignants se retranche derrière la
stricte application des textes sur la
laïcité manifestant ainsi un certain
désaccord avec l'attitude du ministre de
l'éducation nationale